good morning Hank it's Tuesday so it's
not the Star Wars movie again this
weekend and on my fourth viewing I
noticed something really troubling by
the way this video contains no
significant spoilers unless you go to
the movies primarily to see people
separated from their limbs but even then
very mild spoilers lots of people have
complained that the force awakens is
just a rehash of the original Star Wars
movie right even the creator of Star
Wars George Lucas said they wanted to do
a retro movie I don't like that now I
think that view of the movie
oversimplifies it but here's the thing
if it's such a rehash where are all the
severed hands i severed my own hand by
accident over here but I still got it
don't worry so Hank as you pointed out
in a video more than five years ago the
first six Star Wars movies contain no
fewer than 13 severed hands like Anakin
Skywalker despite having two total hands
manages to get one of his hands cut off
three separate times there's even a
phrase in the Star Wars universe for
using your lightsaber to amputate an
opponent's hand show my so hank 3,700
fifty years ago the babylonian king
Hammurabi developed a legal code that
famously uses an eye-for-an-eye
approach to legal retaliation and the
Star Wars universe is kind of similar
except it's a hand for a hand like it's
no coincidence that over the course of
the movies Anakin Skywalker also chops
off three hands in Star Wars the number
one way to risk amputation of your own
hand is to amputate someone else's hand
well unless you're obi-wan Kenobi who by
my count removes nine separate limbs
from people while somehow managing to
remain a tetrapod which yes is the word
for animals with four limbs so anyway
when George Lucas has been asked about
this he always just says well that's
what happens when you play with swords
what you know fair enough but there's
plenty of swordplay in the force awakens
and yet every single hand remains
attached to its body for the entire
movie it's unconscionable meanwhile
Marvel movies have begun chopping off
hands as an homage to Star Wars and no I
am NOT making that up
in fact Marvel Studios President Kevin
Feige has said that it's because of Star
Wars that all the so-called Phase two
Marvel movies feature an arm amputation
Captain America Winter Soldier
definitely guardians of the galaxy check
Iron Man 3 yes and then they burn it an
ant-man kinda insofar as somebody who's
as an arm just before losing the rest of
themselves
nobody's harshing on those movies for
their nostalgia Hank as previously noted
I really liked the force awakens it is
at times nostalgic but I don't think
nostalgia is all bad if
I'd argue the original Star Wars was
also nostalgic it hearkened back to
American westerns and to some
non-existent bygone era when good was
really good and evil was really evil
really if it hadn't been for the
inexcusable failure to chop off any
hands the force awakens would have been
a great movie so I think some of the
blowback is just due to the movies
commercial success most people are never
comfortable loving something
unaccompanied kisses feelings about the
force awakens are probably about
something deeper and not directly
related to its lack of severed hands
basically I think it's really hard for
creators even very successful ones to
see their work go out into the world and
be loved for reasons they didn't intend
like I've found that one of the
pleasures and terrors of writing for an
audience is that the book someone reads
is never quite the book you wrote
inevitably people bring their own
experiences and expectations and desires
to a story and in that process they
change it to use an extreme example when
I was in high school I read The Great
Gatsby and I thought it was crap
that wasn't the great Gatsby's fault on
the other hand Hank when we were little
kids who watched the movie Grease - over
and over and over again on VHS and by
forging that mediocre movie in the
smithy of our souls we were somehow able
to make it great now of course that
isn't to minimize the responsibility of
creators to their creations it's just to
say that once you've done your best and
something is out in the world you have
to let it go basically Hank to me making
stuff is like a Wookiee if you try to
hold on to the stuff you make with too
tight a grip it'll rip your arms right
off Hank I'll see you on Friday